[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace algunos años tuve un paciente
llamado samuel que me decía
en las noches cuando normas se desnudan
para ponerse su negrito me encanta
yo me excito porque ella cuando me ve no
le pasa lo mismo
y norma contestaba un poquito
defendiéndose es que cuando me presionas
no se me antoja y menos cuando estoy
enojada contigo
luego me decía solas
tengo un poco de miedo que se pueda ir
con otra
el desencuentro entre enorme y samuel es
un reflejo de las diferencias del deseo
en parejas estables comprometidas a
largo plazo y con acuerdos de fidelidad
le suena familiar
algunos les ha pasado
yo me casé con el chico que conocí a los
16 años fuimos novios durante 7 años y
estuvimos casados casi 40 años
alberto
a ti te dedico esta plática contigo
aprendí de la pareja del amor de la
sexualidad y del deseo
la vida con alberto me ayudó a entender
la importancia que tiene
la pareja en la vida de todos los
miembros de la familia el trabajo con la
pareja se convirtió en un reto
profesional para mí en 37 años he visto
alrededor de mil parejas muchas de ellas
con problemas de sexualidad algunas con
problemas con el deseo
represión sexual miedo a la intimidad
trastornos del deseo eran el estilo de
explicaciones que yo daba a ese tipo de
problemática en los inicios de mi
carrera y siguiendo protocolos de mi
profesión
pero explicar no es lo mismo que
o no necesariamente es lo mismo que
construir soluciones actualmente me
dedico a la construcción de soluciones y
tengo a mi haber una caja de
herramientas que he ido recopilando a
través de la vida
por eso afirmo que no necesitas
adaptarte a la insatisfacción sexual
puedes resonar sexualmente
hoy en día
tus padres ya no escogen con quién te
vas a casar
el paradigma del matrimonio actual está
basado en la búsqueda de la felicidad
la libre elección el enamoramiento el
amor y entonces cuando las personas se
casan prometen dar y recibir amor
fidelidad intimidad compañerismo y demás
esto para algunos es hasta que la muerte
nos separe
y pueden ser 50 años
entonces cuando estás casado tiene la
expectativa de tener una sexualidad
frecuente plena satisfactoria y que esto
suceda espontáneamente y
es a esa idea de espontaneidad esa
expectativa de espontaneidad allí radica
parte del principal problema porque
seamos honestos parejas estables cuántas
veces en el año les pasa eso que tengan
deseo al mismo tiempo de la misma manera
y en el mismo vídeo la misma forma
y ustedes pensarán bueno yo por eso no
me caso
y en efecto
existen otras alternativas al matrimonio
oa la pareja estable como son relaciones
de infidelidad swingers poliamor
un sexo virtual
masturbación en frente de pornografía y
pueden ser más emocionantes
con sus problemáticas para un siguiente
te toca ya lo estoy preparando
pero muchas parejas siguen con esta idea
de tener una pareja estable
de esta manera casados o no casados
jóvenes gays y entonces cuando las
parejas rompen
acaban con una nueva pareja
recuerdan el del dicho este rey
mismo infierno diferente [ __ ]
las cosas se complican cuando miramos
las reacciones los más viendo las
imágenes de las del cine y de la
televisión de parejas haciendo el amor
con un deseo impresionante que acaban
haciendo el amor en la mesa de la cocina
tirando objetos al piso
contra la pared arrancándose la ropa
y entonces te puedes quedar pensando así
como bueno y a mí por qué no me pasa lo
mismo
o esa química con la pareja lo que está
fallando
emelina grotesque y una educadora sexual
joven talentosa
dice que alrededor del 75% de los
hombres tienen en sus parejas estables
este deseo espontáneo
vertiginoso súbito mientras que sólo 15%
de las mujeres no tienen imaginen
entonces tenemos una dinámica
estas cifras son predominantemente
pero entonces tenemos una dinámica donde
por un lado hay deseo frustración
molestia presión y del otro lado hay una
sensación de uno
pégate de culpa
fastidio
y entonces si esto se repite pues la
sexualidad se vuelve algo que más bien
queremos evitar
porque es demasiado incómodo
hoy les quiero dar tres herramientas
para trabajar con esta dinámica molesta
primera herramienta
detectar y hacer construir el deseo
responsivo
les ha pasado que van a que los invitan
al béisbol o al cine oa una a nadar oa
una fiesta y les da toda la flojera de
ir pero que ya estando allí la pasan
bien
en la sexualidad pasa lo mismo cuando de
repente estás ahí y de repente te
descubres que realmente lo estás pasando
bien aunque te pasas te costó trabajo
empezar es sexo responsivo normal y
típico para muchas mujeres y algunos
hombres el deseo se da de esta manera y
empiezas a hacer el amor por no porque
no se vaya no porque no se moleste no
podrá darle gusto porque lo estás
disfrutando
normal y samuel no tienen que cambiar
como personas trastornadas norma y
samuel pueden elaborar y hacer un
contexto sexualmente positivo donde se
dispare el deseo
la manera inicialmente decía bueno y yo
porque debo de colaborar si yo no tengo
bronca si a mí se me hace súper normal
y luego entendió que el sexo automático
no le encantaba y norma pasiva - y que
era importante tomarla en cuenta para
que las cosas funcionaran
norma a su vez pues le dio bastante
gusto recuperar eso que claro que sí le
gusta
segunda herramienta
a pagar los frenos de la excitación
quiero que recuerden esa sensación que
tenemos cuando aprendemos el coche
queremos acelerar y tenemos freno de
mano puesto
no se puede verdad nuestro cerebro
sexual funciona con aceleradores y con
frenos a la excitación
frenos pueden ser
un olor
puede ser el cansancio puede ser el
recuerdo de un crédito
entre muchos otros
y normalmente nos ayuda a tener frenos
pues nos ayuda a no tener una sexualidad
desenfrenada descontrolada pero en la
relación estable pues si son un
impedimento
tenemos sensibilidades diferentes
algunos tenemos frenos muy fuertes es
decir fácilmente nos detenemos y a ver
este esto seguro es confiable
esto no es muy cambiarle porque es parte
del temperamento lo que sí es muy
cambiable son los estímulos a los que
obedece el freno porque esos los fuimos
aprendiendo en el camino
cada caso requiere una solución un poco
diferente por eso es importante que la
pareja se siente lo platiqué lo recuerde
haga un autoanálisis investigue
se transforme en algo así como un
detective de los frenos y de los botones
que los apagan por ejemplo
él
el cuerpo nuestra nuestra nuestra
conciencia del cuerpo que tenemos puede
ser un freno tremendo muy poderoso
entonces cuando está la pareja viendo la
tele y el esposo julián las pompis de
una chica y acto seguido que era la
esposa fogosa en la cama pues
funciona mejor coquetear y seducir y que
haya un intel fuego que prepare el
contexto sexualmente positivo o que
estás en la cama y tu mujer te empieza a
acariciar y tú estás con se me olvidó
sacar la ropa
y además de hecho la presentación
el relajamiento
el manejo del estrés y la ansiedad son
herramientas que nos sirven en general
en la vida
en la sexualidad son muy importantes
tercera herramienta prender los
aceleradores de la excitación
y el acelerador es todo lo que arranca
lo que me pone
actualmente están muy de moda algunas
ayudas como por ejemplo leer literatura
erótica ver películas porno utilizar
juguetes sexuales disfrazarse jugar
roles
y claro pueden ayudar porque no
pero aguas porque si está el freno de
mano puesto
ojalá
y quiero darles hoy dos ideas
como somos muy variables y nos gustan
cosas muy diferentes es muy importante
tener un consenso es decir entre adultos
todo se vale siempre y cuando sea
consensuado y les doy dos ideas
una idea es que cuando hagan una cita
con su pareja sea algo excitante algo
divertido algo diferente
algo que te haga crecer como persona o
que los haga crecer como pareja
se ha demostrado que cuando hay eventos
excitantes de este estilo el deseo crece
naturalmente y segunda idea todos hemos
tenido éxito y hemos estado en una
situación sexual agradable
recordar los detalles de nuestras
experiencias óptimas es sumamente
importante porque porque nos dice cómo
hacerlo nos pone en el mundo y nos
recuerda que es posible
que ganarías tú en tu relación de pareja
se implementan las tres herramientas
te invito a crear contextos sexualmente
positivos donde se dispare el deseo
responsivo la excitación se apaguen los
frenos y metamos aceleradores siempre es
posible re encender la sexualidad y
poder resonar sexualmente
[Aplausos]